اطباء مصر لا يشعرون بالانصاف هكذا يقول
من هاجر منهم الى بريطانيا فهم تركوا
قطاعا صحيا قالوا انه ياخذوا منهم اكثر
مما يعطيهم لا ماديا فقط وانما معنويا
وذهنيا الدكتور مصطفى عبد الله والدكتوره
هند الديب من بين اكثر من 11 الف طبيب
مصري غادروا قطاع الصحه في مصر ما بين
و2022 وفقا لنقابه الاطباء المصريه
ساعات عمل طويله او الموازنه من العمل
وبين الحياه طبعا بيبقى صعب شويه وطبعا
مشكله كبيره جدا في مصر في مجال الطبي
الحكومي هي الفلوس وده برضو من احد اسباب
الكبيره جدا اغلبيه الناس اللي موجوده في
انجلترا مصريين بيجوا عشان يطلعوا من هذه
المشكله وبيجوا البلد ثانيه احنا شايفينها
بنحترم اكتر الاطباء وبتديهم فلوس انوف او
تديهم
يعني او تقدير من حيث مد او معنوي او او
احترام عامه في الشغل عامه من عشره 15 سنه
بردو احنا مكناش على التواصل مع الدكاتره
التانيه فكنا فاكرين ان ده الطبيعي
اه كنا عارفين ان في امريكا وفي انجلترا
وفي الدول
عندهم نظام احسن مننا كثير بس اللي
اكتشفناه ان لا حتى في دول الجيران دينا
في افريقيا واسيا عندهم ترينينج احسن مننا
بمراحل وعندهم او السالوري بتاعهم كمان
احسن مننا
نفوق لان لا
الوضع في كل الدول والدول دي مش هتحلينا
اقتصاديا في الحلقه الاقتصاديه وفي الحاله
التعليميه وفي كل حاجه طب ليه العديد من
الاطباء المصريين وجدوا في بريطانيا مكانا
لتحقيق احلامهم المهنيه سمعنا الاسباب
التي جاءوا من اجلها وروايه وصولهم الى
هنا لكن القصه لا تبدا من هنا تبدا من
هناك من مصر وزميلنا احمد عثمان سيروي لنا
هذه القصه من هناك
بالفعل ماذا حدث به عدد من الاطباء
المصريين المقيمين في لندن يمثل واقع
المؤلما لعشرات الالاف من الاطباء
المصريين
كريم حسين احد هؤلاء الحالمين بالتوجه
للعاصمه البريطانيه متخرج منذ خمسه اعوام
ومتخصص في مجال الكبد دخله الشهري من
العمل في المستشفى الحكومي
4200 جنيه اي ما يقرب من 150 دولارا اغلب
الاطباء بيفكروا له جات لهم فرصه ان هو
يسافر ولكن ده مش هروبا من من اداء الخدمه
الطبيه في مصر ولكن بيبقى بحث للتعليم
الطبي ان هو يسافر يتعلم افضل يلاقي فرص
تعليم طبيه افضل بره نفسه الامل يسيطر على
اجيال اكبر احمد بيومي المتخصص في مجال
علم النفس تخرج منذ 13 عاما يركز حاليا
على استكمال دراسه الزماله البريطانيه
استعدادا للرحيل الرغبه دايما في عالم
البحث عن عالم جديد يكون في واجبات واضحه
حقوق واضحه نسبه التعدي على الاطباء اللي
ظهرت في المستشفيات اثناء ازمه كورونا
وفيما بعد قبلها وفيما بعدها يؤدي الى
نزوح كتير او تفكير كتير من الاطباء في
الى الخارج للتحصيل العلمي والاستلام
والبحث عن الامان الانساني والاماني
المادي ايضا نقابه الاطباء حذرت من
تداعيات هذا النزوح الكبير ده انذار كبير
جدا جدا وخطوره كبيره جدا ولازم انبه ان
مش زياده عدد الطلاب ودخول طلاب كليات
الطب هيبقى هو الحل زياده عدد وخريجي
كليات الطب سيؤدي الى زياده عدد الاجر
لابد من حل التلات اسباب اللي بيؤدي
الهجره الاطباء التدريب والتعليم الطبي
المستمر بيئه العمل المناسبه ودخل الاطباء
وقد تكون ازمه هجره الاطباء رساله جاده
للدوله بضروره سرعه اعتماد رؤيه جديده
للحفاظ على مستقبل مصر من الاطباء احمد
عثمان العربيه القاهره